Greetings, everybody.
My name is Sam Deiter, and I'm a senior Unreal Engine
instructor with Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial series,
we're going to be taking a look at some advanced landscape
techniques you can apply to your massive open worlds
inside of Unreal Engine 5.
We are first going to start off by taking a look at how
we can initially set up any project that requires landscape
to be successful by covering a number of settings that
should be enabled when you first create your project.
We're then going to take a look at how we can create a
landscape material that will utilize the landscape's slope
to help reveal different textures inside
of that material.
The great thing about setting up our material in this way
means that as we sculpt our landscape,
the look of the landscape will follow this,
allowing us to have a semi-procedural setup
and not have to worry about manually texturing or painting
texture information.
We'll then take a look at how we can set up our level,
whether we're using one of the templates that's provided
or a blank level, and better understand the required actors
and logic to the setup that's required for any type of world
that requires a landscape or a massive open world.
We'll finally finish up by taking
a look at the various tools Unreal Engine 5 provides
to help edit and manage the different components, actors,
and settings that are required for massive open worlds.
We've got a lot to cover in this video tutorial series,
so let's go ahead and get started
by taking a look at our initial project setup.